[Music]
hey everyone its Peter Brown standing in
for freelancer Daniel Starkey for his
review of Dark Souls 3 the ring city the
cobblestone pathways and towering
cathedrals of the eponymous ring city
twist and melt into one another as they
fall into oblivion here at the edge of
the world and old woman quips that she
feels like a God looking over all
creation as it races towards the end of
everything these twisted landscapes make
for a surreal backdrop and a fitting
metaphor for the final chapter of Dark
Souls it's fortunate then that the Ring
City doesn't waste any of that creative
energy as weird as the world of Dark
Souls can be the brutality tends to keep
them grounded and tangible with the ring
city however these pretenses fall away
your introduction shunts you through a
series of monster packed corridors
interspersed with steep bizarrely
non-lethal drops down cliffs these show
your gradual descent into the
nightmarish plane of the ring city an
apparent mosaic of the settings of the
series other entries now caked in ash
and dust and balance moments of
desperation against bursts of fatalism
it's striking tense and emblematic of
the expansion as a whole the ring city
takes all of Dark Souls ideas and
presses them to the extreme in previous
games high-risk high-reward play was
advantageous but here it's essential you
won't find your first bonfire a shelter
from the universe's grotesque monsters
for quite some time and even then it
doesn't seem too useful you'll rush out
and die without a chance to learn much
angels guard much of the area and they
can spot you from some ways off the
subsequent salvo of golden light Spears
can tear through your health in an
instant if you're not careful and these
angels can't be killed directly at first
that seems like a breach of the series
guiding mantra of tough but fair
however it's there to upend expectations
and encourage new styles of play in this
case stealth which the series had yet to
explore once you know where and how to
move the area is still a challenge but
in true Souls fashion it's far from
insurmountable
it's a shame then that the ring cities
brisk pace just isn't enough to give
these new ideas the attention they
deserve just as each new concept starts
coming into view you move on an
undercurrent of weighty themes in the
dense overworld more than compensate
however as I send off for this trilogy
the Ring City has to tie a lot of
disparate threads together and it
manages this by focusing on its
characters figures like patches a
deceitful murderous thief conclude their
arcs here
people in the Dark Souls universe fade
as their will does over time they lose
their minds and go hollow throughout the
series this little bit of lore has been
leveraged as an analog for the player if
the game gets too hard and you give up
your avatar could be thought of as going
hollow within the game world it's
telling them that on the precipice of
the apocalypse the folks who made it are
dogged albeit with banal drives these
games have always used conviction of
purpose as an analog for how a weak
willed person can persist in spite of
suffering patches while he lacks
compassion and strength of character
lives on through greed and suffering
tortured though his soul may be
unearthing what sorts of karma this
world holds for cheats becomes one of a
series of lenses the ring city holds up
for you as it asks you to look back on
your time with these characters and
stories and reflect on what they've
meant to you oh we are head square on
your shorter is it I thought that
clamoring tin can
lost about hey here we go again anyone
less interested in dissecting what it
all means we'll have plenty to chew on
as well the Ring City has a total of
four unique bosses more than any other
such add-on for any game in the series
and confronting each is a blast nothing
here is half done and it shows as with
the rest of the expansion bosses here
remix classic ideas and incorporate a
bevy of new twists such as inviting
players to fight alongside a boss in
against you another series first the
last duel is a poetic conclusion pitting
you against a force tied to the fate of
the world and one of the series biggest
mysteries the story of the furtive pygmy
the fight is raw and chaotic with your
enemy mirroring the patterns and strikes
of Artorias a warrior corrupted by
darkness and the central figure of the
five-year-old artorias of the abyss
expansion exactly who the final boss of
the series is I'll leave out but it does
provide a perfect narrative arc for the
franchise to end on C is like that R
where Dark Souls succeeds best it's not
just inventive level design or epic boss
battles or even an engaging story
it's the merging of them all and that's
made even more memorable when the
choreography of a battle gives slight
nods to its inspiration make no mistake
though while the ring city much like
Dark Souls 3 as a whole leans a bit on
nostalgia and illusions it earns in a
steam space along its forebears
the ring city moves and ends a little
too quickly well before it gets all the
mileage you can out of its settling and
premises but that's a small knock
against what's otherwise an exceptional
send-off a well of inspired locales and
a renewed focus on the series obsession
with cycles death and rebirth in the
passage of time plus a few spectacularly
designed and animated foes round out a
worthy conclusion to a storied franchise
[Music]
you